non mais c'est vrai Sophie
non mais c'est vrai que Sophie Coste qui
fait son retour je peux vous dire que là
en ce moment j'entends énormément parler
d'elle et de son physique et il y a une
photo qu'elle aille posté sur insta qui
a bouleversé Raymond oh non
je vais vous raconter toute l'histoire
j'en ai rien à je raconte tout je
balance tout Raymond j'étais
tranquillement dans ma loge il y a
quelques jours on tape à ma porte
première fois je réponds-moi
voilà toujours est mal à Baby tricks là
ça rattrape une deuxième fois je dis oh
ça maintenant qu'est-ce que vous voulez
je suis occupé
à quoi tu fais quoi
un jeu sur le portable
un jeu de basket extraordinaire et donc
ça retape je suis quand même aller voir
Raymond Raymond mais alors tout feu tout
flamme tu me dis est-ce que tu es allé
sur insta de Sophie cost je suis sur un
stade personne et là il me dit j'ai
quelque chose à te montrer ah ouais et
là il me montre une photo de Sophie
Coste à la piscine Sophie était là son
boule était dans la maison
et là
il me dit mon sang n'a fait qu'un tour
et il m'a dit je lui ai dit
oui qu'est-ce que tu m'as dit exactement
je me souviens terme
à la piscine devant
voilà il était un peu dans une piscine
municipale
j'étais nue mais j'ai hésité en fait à
la poster cette photo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas grand chose en fait j'étais dans la
piscine donc j'avais pas de maillot de
bain mais on voyait pas ni ma poitrine
on voyait un peu en fait la courbe des
rats voilà
[Rires]
moi j'ai même pas regardé
alors
quand je rentre à la maison mon fils qui
a 16 ans m'a dit
maman
et je lui ai dit ben écoute en fait
voilà oui je peux comprendre
j'ai pas vu la photo non mais juste
à poil dans une piscine à cette époque
je me baignais un pote qui a une piscine
couverte non elle était pas couverte
mais elle était chauffée
moi aussi j'ai un podcast
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est turcs et pourquoi tu quittes une
piscine toi
tout le monde
cet été à la fin de l'été là
il parle français
[Rires]
en Angleterre le gars n'est pas clair
en fait il est guingampère et il est
sans déconner peut-être attends et donc
je me suis demandé mais alors
les Turcs les Turcs c'est où tournent ça
c'est ça physiquement c'est où tout
est bon ou très médiocre non mais
vraiment je connais moi
mais lui il en avait
[Rires]
je suis allé je suis allé au Mexique
frère déjà frère les Mexicains ils sont
ils ont pas ils sont pas hyper grands
Baba j'ai l'impression que je faisais
deux mètres 12
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux toi en fait
vas-y qu'est-ce qui t'arrive t'as
Beaujolais
mais c'est un truc de ouf et les mecs
ces gars c'est en fait c'est pas grave
parce que souvent ils sont très ils
peuvent être très bons mais en fait
comme Pépito d'ailleurs qui est
magnifique
hein mais c'est vrai et donc voilà
tu en es où ah ouais Mexique ils sont
magnifiques avec une Mexicaine
franchement je vais vous dire c'était il
y a 25 ans
non non non mais je suis pas méchante
avec une Mexicaine
faut arrêter moi quoi
on se concentre sur toi bien sûr tu en
es où toi je suis célibataire
est-ce que tu aimes
les mecs
qui aiment livrer
ah oui ah oui
[Rires]
que parfois n'ont pas un moral d'acier
est-ce que tu serais quelqu'un qui
pourrait remettre un petit coup ça
pourrait le faire c'est vrai exactement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
par un livreur
possible
qui habitait en Grèce est-ce que tu veux
pas être avec un mec qui habite
Pontault-Combault qui parle
Pontault-Combault et qui parle de moi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce qu'on a vraiment à côté
il est parfois juste à côté
le dimanche même un coup de balai sur le
camion tu le nettoies
[Applaudissements]
il est fidèle il est il est il est
souvent dans les ténèbres
il plonge souvent dans les ténèbres il
est coupé il est équipé là
ça n'a rien à voir
je suis pas ténébreux je suis désolé
moi oubliez-moi moi lui lui pourquoi lui
gênant
vous voulez que je vous dise je le
connais alors je t'explique c'est
attention à lui
surprise il peut te faire changer d'avis
c'est mon avis
[Rires]
devant la porte devant la porte
il l'a fait il l'a fait